what's up reject nation I'm Greg I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
trailer from a twenty four st. Maude so
you know it's gonna be a fast pace jump
scare horror thriller because it's a 24
and that's what they always give you
with films like the witch non-stop
thrills hereditary mid samar countless
other ones these are crowd-pleasers and
deed I would love it if we watch it
sound like oh it is the thing they
really change your style oh they're
making it mainstream not a slow burn
horror movie it'll be a good time and
this is a topper war tear video requests
from loyal patronage act new Raj Krishna
on thanks buddy
merry xmas to you and your brother hope
you're watching a lot of films let's get
into this
Wow what above Christ
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
other vibes rumors
[Music]
Rosemary's Baby
amen to that
Oh know that what are you doing
self-flagellation holy Oh God
you might be you might be right about
that their savior is coming it looks
like a like a holy Dumont like
possession movie like instead of being
possessed by a demon here possessed by
God horrifically freaky God twisted
version of God
nah yeah you gotta love it man that's an
8 24 8 or if I didn't know 1 it's
goddamn super creepy I think this film
is gonna just like the films that are
saying that the studio brought you it's
gonna be deliberately pasted gonna have
a real insidious build to it all work
sure will start off like slow normal and
then it'll just progressively probably
line into territory like what the hell's
going on by the finale you're like that
was one of the weird things I've seen
all year 24 doesn't like their descent
into madness
it seems oh yeah yeah you gotta love it
man that main actress looks great
religious horror is the one that really
gets under my skin the most growing up
Catholic and seeing these twisted
versions of worship you got this cult
vibe here that kind of made me think a
little bit of mother some Rosemary's
Baby kind of vibe what I like about it
is she's this caretaker from least one
with a trailer at the sense I got she's
a caretaker of getting involved in this
law religious cult of sorts and the
reason I'm saying mother and Rosemary's
babies because she seems like she's an
important piece of the puzzle she's not
just opening the door to discovering
something it seems like she is the
savior they're talking about like this
thing like the woman s soul for it yeah
yeah something like that which I love I
love that well maybe that's it maybe
it's like a weird horrific second coming
of Christ but you know shoved into
somebody else's body or something like
that you know like the spirit invades
you or something like that that's the
impression I'm getting I'm bet it's
gonna be a good character study of this
person as well but they seem to just be
knocking it out of the park with it
let's do who's the Kevin Feige of a
twenty because someone has this very
specific vision and gets these directors
on bore like any directors I don't know
who Rose glasses you know female
directors really are able to make a
strong impression
horror films that's not it seems to be
the yeah staple for you want to find
some great female directors you'd go to
horror yeah I mean there's so much more
horror in waking life for women I would
imagine yeah just just as the default
setting in this world that we live in
and it's cool because Edgar not right
who Robert Iger is he did the witch are
a stirred did mid Samar and hereditary
and all three of those films have like
female main characters and this is the
first one that it's directed by a woman
I mean I don't know all the 824
filmography off my hand
the main one do you associate with a 24
this one that they're pushing here in
December is the celebration of Christ's
Christmas watch this horror to go along
with all the happy but to get a female
director for this with a female lead and
it seems like most of the cast is female
yeah well it's an interesting thing
because if it does take a very religious
you know context that's also a strange
place for women the history of the
church and various religions are not
altogether kind to women
whoa-oh-oh-oh they've been way meaner to
men oh sure just society in general it's
made a lot harder on me especially in
the last couple of years yeah it has
gotten a little bit uncomfortable to be
a man well maybe that's what'll happen
at the end maybe a man will finally get
his due and he will triumph over this
possessed God leading I mean they're
talking about their saviors come and I
hope it's a white male yes that's what
we need maybe it can be Adam Sandler you
know he's done promoting uncut and he
came in and did this little indie
religious thriller because you know he
must hate Catholicism just that much or
Christianity whichever this was
Scientology job oh they do have an
interesting taste though of all the
studios out there they are the one may
be other than Blum House where it's like
you can not even see their bumper but
sort of guess it's probably one of their
I mean this one's a little bit different
maybe because of this song they chose to
put over it like happily Island having
the lyric of
but I figured all the good girls go to
hell yeah having that lyric fits
perfectly with it a little bit of that
hop flare made for a different type of
edited trailer yeah but you know it's
gonna be in a 24 yeah music is airy and
sparse and you know patient we're aware
of it so even even that kind of matches
the vibe I guess some of the vibe that I
get from the trailer makes it seem like
she has good and tensions if that makes
sense
like she's a nurse right well yeah and
they mentioned that thing about like
wanting to save the soul of the people
that she's it's like it's easy to clean
up after the dead but to save their soul
as the true challenge or whatever yeah
some of the vibe I'm getting is that
she's getting more involved in this
crazy religious stuff to help the
patient yeah yeah yeah maybe she's going
to lose herself in the pursuit of
salvation I've had nurses like that
mm-hmm mm-hmm
Kaiser Permanente yeah dude that HMO
insurance really horrific medical option
all right guys well st. Maude are you
excited for this film do you like this
style of a24 do you prefer these kind of
deliberate pace madness tales as a post
here it's and conjuring comment below
you guys can subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification well you
get notified whenever we got a youtube
video up Anna ROG thank you so much for
requesting this my dude we waited awhile
for your request to come in a month and
I was like all right man we got to get
you requested before the month is over
that's part of the deal and then you
sent this in a little bit before
Christmas Day you know how to celebrate
the holidays I don't know what the hell
you're doing if this is what's on your
mind at this time of year but I hope
you're all right Jesus is watching you
so just keep that in mind I don't think
he's gonna be very happy about this
especially his birthday secular
birthdays like maybe he has a sixth
sense of humor maybe maybe Jesus loves
these movies secretly sits up there he's
like ha ha
it's not what it's like so Niraj have
some wine with christ this year I don't
think that is your religion anywho we'll
talk soon buddy may the Lord be with you
you